We've looked at some exponential functions. But, now we're going to take a
short break from them to look at representing very small and very large
numbers. Imagine you want to travel to the far, far regions of the known
universe. Out past Mars, right past Pluto, out past where Voyager is sending
back images, far beyond our own galaxy, past our nearest neighbor, Andromeda.
On, and on, and on, traveling over. Well, traveling a very long distance, a
distance so long that it's hard to express with words. We could write this out
as 5, another 5, and then 22 zeros if you want to talk about it in miles. In
kilometers, this would be 8, 8, and then 22 zeros, or perhaps you want to
examine some bacteria. How big is a tiny organism like this. If we wanted to
talk about how long the bacteria is, we could write it like this, 0.0000005 m.
Apart from it being really boring to write out all those zeros, it's easy to
make a mistake when we write out numbers like this, and it's also hard to read.
We really need a better way to write quantities like this. And guess what,
there is one. It's called scientific notation. And as you've already seen, it's
very useful, especially when we're talking about very big and very small
quantities. Let's get ready to talk about it.